a whistleblower alleges that the United
States has recovered intact alien
spacecraft and people have called me and
said David why aren't you covering it
are you scared so here's the deal I want
you to tell me is this something I
should cover what we have are the claims
of a whistleblower saying the U.S has
intact extraterrestrial technology we
have no evidence of that
and it is contradictory to a pentagon
report about uh unidentified aerial
phenomena from two years ago so I have
the claim of a whistleblower
and then I have no evidence whatsoever
so what can I really say the conspiracy
theorists say the absence of evidence is
part of the cover-up but I don't have
any evidence of that and I try to do on
my content on my show
that for which I have evidence